Hey, this is jad from Radiolab.
So we were not planning on releasing a podcast today, but then Friday apple,
the federal government tonight outlining and elaborate expensive and
extraordinary assault on us democracy,
teen Russian nationals and three Russian companies accused of a massive effort.
Unless you have been living under a rock for the past three days,
you've probably heard that the special council Robert Muller Guy,
that president Trump keeps accusing of being engaged in a witch hunt.
He has handed down some indictments.
The defendants allegedly conducted what they call information warfare against
the United States. They say the Russians were right here in the u s too.
The indictment says the Russians tried to create chaos going so far as to travel
to the states.
The Russians allegedly sent operatives to America traveling throughout nine
states.
No.
The picture that you get from the indictment is that there was this sort of like
shadowy network of Russian nationals that had infiltrated the country with the
idea of sowing chaos in the run up to the 2016 election.
And we just sort of wondered very simply like who are these Russians and who are
these Americans that were manipulated? How did it, how did it work,
how do they feel about things now?
So what we decided to do for this podcast just cause we were curious and just
cause you know,
it's fun for a podcast like ours to try and do fast turnaround stuff.
On occasion we decided to see what we could find out.
Producer Simon Adler takes it from here.
[inaudible]
sure. Hey Charles, are you there? Hey, how are you doing Simon?
I'm doing all right. Little sleepy, but other than that I'm good.
So not too long ago,
I got in touch with this radio producer reporter based in Moscow by the name of
Charles mains. Do you want to do video? Just say hello? Uh, yeah,
that'd be great. Uh, I'm in a cert of my pajamas, but yeah, that's fine.
[inaudible] it was like three in the morning, New York time. But, but anyways,
um, the reason I got in touch with him with to have him help facilitate and
interpret an interview with this guy. Hi, my name is [inaudible].
Um, I am from Russia. I forgot about St, uh, St Spetters book. I'm so, I'm a,
I'm very bad speak English. Oh No, don't worry about it. That's why I went,
that's what you got Charles for. Yes, yes, yes. Oh, thank you. A chalice.
I'm translating. Okay, great. Uh, yeah, sure. Let's just start with like,
where are you from originally?
I'm just curious like a little bit about who you are.
[inaudible] the Vitaly, the spell of,
I mean he's a kid from a small town in Siberia.
[inaudible] small town near Kazakhstan and he said from an early age, uh,
it was clear that he just really didn't fit in up there cause they'll upset with
[inaudible]. He had blue hair for a time dressed like a goth
[inaudible] to be this kind of alternative character in Siberia is an easy
thing. I mean,
he would tell these stories about walking down the street and I'm fooling. Yeah,
I get that. Don't know. It's kind of tough guys with short haircuts.
They're calling him faggot. Oh it just showed that Dah Dah, Dah. You just
[inaudible]. And so when he gets a chance to get out, he does,
he moves to St Petersburg, considered one of the most liberal cities in Russia.
And he moved there not looking for just any job but specifically to be a
journalist cause that is [inaudible], which he really felt was his calling.
So bill here,
Bethlehem refers to journalists as like superheroes or Batman
know. So he heads the St Petersburg and he thinks he's all set up.
He's got a job with a local website. He's going to do some editing for them.
Maybe a little writing, but right away with w within short order,
I believe the story is he,
our business dried up and so did the newspaper and suddenly the tally is out of
the job. Well [inaudible] so and so, it's kind of a crisis moment,
uh, multiple choice, a tough.
So he starts looking around and he's, as he describes it, he gets up every day,
starts sending out all these resumes,
[inaudible] scholars call this call doing searches.
Just find anybody to who will do anything that would let him use his writing
skills. Just trying to find something to do with text. Until finally,
after almost a month of this,
he comes across this one ad that it's not really clear what they're offering or
who's offering it, but, uh,
it mentions that there's some copy editing to be done,
some writing and uh, the pay scale seems a lot higher.
It's if they're promising double the money that, uh, most people, uh,
are offered for, for working in journalism in Russia.
[inaudible] right away he just thought this was just weird, but you know,
of course he's interested, um, how could he not be? And so he places a call
now it's worth noting everything that is about to happen in fatality.
We weren't able to fact check 100%, but that being said,
it does line up squarely with what others have reported. So anyway,
fast forward a couple of days he ends up having an interview and they offer him
the job, which he accepts,
although I'll still not really knowing what the heck it is he will be doing.
Exactly. It's just not really clear what it, what it is. Okay.
So tell me about that first day like a let the younger class [inaudible] goes
in. You described initially just going into the, to the entering into the foyer,
the building into the entrance.
The building itself is cement four stories tall and the security is,
is oddly strict. Like when he went up to them,
they required him to hand over a bunch of documents like his passport, uh,
just to get in. That's his first impression. [inaudible]
potentially his boss shows up. This woman named Ana,
she walks him down the halls and he said the whole place had liked the feel of a
hospital.
[inaudible] long corridors with little rooms to the left and right people
behind, um, keyboards working on computers. And it's almost completely silent
except for the tapping of fingers on keys. Anyway,
eventually they, they duck into a room on, uh, shows him his desk.
And this is finally when he gets a sense of what exactly is going on.
Honest sits them down and says, we're doing news about Ukraine. Um,
we just want you to write articles. It was 20 articles a day.
He had to do sort of massage the text for.
But the thing is these didn't have to be brand new articles. Um,
but instead he was told essentially take this article that's already been
written,
somebody else's article and add to it and then change the content.
So it's 70% original. So what's important to know here is, uh,
this was 2014 and uh,
praying within the early days of the civil war,
the apocalyptic scene in central Kiev tonight, this morning, key f again,
a work to the sound of gunfire,
a civil war that Russia wanted to influence the outcome of and to do so they
started experimenting with this new form of propaganda. That's right.
What you saw was this campaign that was going on two fronts with on the one hand
you had state media, you know,
the sort of pro government media here being broadcast from Russia, uh,
into Ukraine, uh, spinning the narrative for those watching.
But then you have certain amount of the population that perhaps doesn't watch
state media.
And this is where you get into this effort to kind of plug the holes in this
story, uh, online,
no, no. Is what Vitali had been hired to do. Just, you know,
to steal that story. So the [inaudible], you know,
they told him to take an article that was about Ukraine.
For example, according to fatale,
there was an incident in which a group of pro-Russian rebels had taken over his
school in Ukraine, essentially holding the kids hostage.
And when the pro Ukrainian soldiers, when they, when they stormed the school,
children died. [inaudible].
Now this actually happened and was covered by the Ukrainian media,
but ana, as I recall her name is Ana Vitaly. His boss says like, look,
your goal is to take this real news story and rewrite it,
leaving out the fact that there were ever any pro Russian troops there creating
the impression that the pro Ukrainian troops had stormed the school and
massacred these children for no reason at all. Uh, [inaudible].
And so once he had be written this article and made these small changes
[inaudible] site, now horse photographer would create a website with a dot.
UAA address. This is a Ukraine address,
a site that looked like a local online Ukrainian newspaper,
extensively written by Ukrainians for Ukrainian audience.
So he's being asked to write about Ukraine as if he was writing from Ukraine.
Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
We'll explain premium [inaudible] and Tali the way he describes it while he's
working on this newspapers, uh, involving events in Ukraine,
pretending to be Ukrainian journalists.
He's citing blogs that are written extensively by Ukrainians and he's pretty
sure that blogger is upstairs in the next level up inside this building in St
Petersburg. So it's a feedback loop.
We'll end. Uh,
so I'm presuming on day one you've shown up there, uh,
with these high minded journalistic ideals and you have to realize that you've
gotten yourself into something that, uh,
in no way lives up to those ideals.
How on earth did that feel? Camilo [inaudible]
oh, it's mutual. And solicit to solicit a counsel,
go to [inaudible].
This is where it gets this really important moment where he's trying to decide
what to do. And he says to himself that he had kind of two thoughts, which is,
you know, I a, you get out of there and never come back.
Or B, you do go back and find out more what,
what's going on there and it gets this idea that, you know what,
maybe I've got a scoop here, maybe I can do an investigation.
He sort of assigned himself to be kind of an undercover agent. Exactly.
Uh,
okay. Uh, just to, to zoom out here for a second,
the job that fatale had taken was with an organization known as the Internet
research agency and then called the Internet research agency, Church Agency,
Internet research agency, shadowy Russian organization,
which we've heard so much about in these past 72 hours.
It's a private company established in 2013 by a Putin ally named Yevgeny per
goes in. Yep. Guinea pigs version.
A Russian businessman with close ties to Vladimir Putin who along with being the
bearer of a rather strange nickname chef to President Vladimir Putin,
but he's also one of the Russian nationals mentioned in the Muller indictment.
Now in the early days when Vitali was working there, uh,
it was his impression that there were roughly a couple hundred people working at
the Internet research agency. But at its peak, the organization grew to,
uh, to employ as many as a thousand people with an annual budget of millions of
dollars headed by a management group and arranged into departments including
graphics, search engine optimization,
information technology and finance departments. Now, as the Tali told us,
it was hard to know exactly what happened in this place because everyone was so
siloed. But over his time there, he was able to make sense of some of it.
The first floor was filled with people just like fatale writing fake articles
for fake sites. Second floor,
it was known as the Social Media Department and these folks were responsible for
pumping out liens like one where Hillary Clinton is shaking hands with the
devil. The third floor was filled with people writing fake blogs,
the same blogs that Vitaly would pull quotes from.
And on the fourth floor you'd find the youtube and Facebook commenting trolls
along
with the cafeteria.
[inaudible] you couldn't, one [inaudible] once was a 24 seven operation.
They never,
they never stopped making news and they never spot stopped generating content.
Well, and who are your coworkers? It's dumb old
[inaudible] were quite a few people from other towns of Russia that moved to St
Petersburg. There were some people who said, we're frankly, you know,
activists in the opposition, but there are a lot of people that you know, like,
you know, they check in, they check out for work.
They just punched the clock and a, you know,
for them it was just like mopping the floor or you know,
or taking out the trash.
Did you feel some guilt or misgivings about what you were doing?
A [inaudible] glass
[inaudible] he describes being really stressed out during this whole period
[inaudible] cause while he was, you know, on the one hand,
I suppose he's gathering good material for what will hopefully be some grand
exposited they told right. On the other hand,
he just felt like he was just living this lie.
Eventually after three and a half months, Vitaly did quit. And as he tells it,
he had enough. And just didn't feel like he could learn anything else.
And so with his months of research,
he went on to write an article in Russia that really didn't make a splash at all
in part because the Internet research agency was already a pretty well known
organization in Russia at that time. Uh,
essentially other journalists had just beaten him to the punch. But then
[inaudible]
in the wake of the 2016 election with accusations of Russian meddling beginning
to [inaudible]
tonight,
a look inside Russia's disinformation campaign from 26 year old Vitale best
Bella,
the American media took notice and Fatali got a call from NBC.
Is this it? This is the building. Yes, yes, yes, yes, of course.
The troll factory. Yes.
Purest. And a pink sweater on, uh,
Vitaly answered questions for this brief evening news segment.
Did you create fake accounts? Yes. He says, oh,
so you believe that this operation was backed by the Kremlin of subtle?
Absolutely. He says [inaudible] also believes it's still up and running.
The Kremlin denies it, suggesting reports the factory even existed.
My feet fate,
NBC, NBC at the bully. Uh, and from that moment on, he really did
became the Goto guy.
If you wanted to talk to somebody who had worked inside journalists from all
over the world, started reaching out to him.
[inaudible] asking for interviews or comments. Keep in mind,
these are all international journalists, none of them Russian until one day.
Not long after all.
Yeah. So,
so he gets a call from this national tilt television channels saying basically
in, in an hour,
we're gonna run a story about you and we really want you to come on our talk
show, no bullying [inaudible] and he said, look, I'm busy. I'm working,
you know, you know, I can't
do it. And so, you know, they run right.
This piece, I'm going to ask you to
[inaudible] cogs in this TV studio on this set that looked like a cross between
sort of the family feud and an evening news broadcast.
The Trump are the hosts just start kicking Vitaly of heart and flashing images
of him on this giant screen behind them.
What they've got is they kind of mind his online persona.
They've got him hanging out in a, in a, in a club,
making funny faces with the camera version of
sub chat, start kind of digging through his political views,
the fact that he's a supporter of the liberal opposition
[inaudible] you know, and, and they just, you know,
make them out to be this kind of freak and they're all laughing at him and you
know, he's, it's just a, it's just an absolute public flogging,
a total public humiliation. Wow. Um,
well he got caught in his own little misinformation, uh,
loop there at the end. Yeah, yeah, that's right.
[inaudible]
yeah. Look, the
[inaudible] [inaudible] what's interesting is Batali, you know,
the way he describes it is that, you know, in some ways when he was there,
it was, they were just trying to figure out the mechanisms.
It was getting more sophisticated.
And as he's leaving his time is ending at the Internet research agency.
He says that there was just about this time and he started seeing these posts,
uh, for vacancies, um, in other languages,
including English.
Well, those 2000 [inaudible].
So in a way he is for him.
It's this moment where he sees the troll farm,
the troll factory suddenly turning outward.
Well now three years later, uh, we know a bit more about [inaudible]
this English initiative. In 2014,
the company established a translator project focused on the United States.
And July of 2016 more than 80 employees were assigned to the translator project.
And many of those employees apparently took some of the moves from there,
Ukraine Info war playbook and use the pointed them at the u s the Russians also
recruited and paid real Americans to engage in political activities from Ho
political campaigns and stage political rallies.
The defendants and their co-conspirators pretended to be grassroots activists.
In fact, I spoke to one reporter who told me about this incident in Houston, uh,
when there were two protests
happening at the same time on one side of the street,
a white nationalist protest and on the other,
a group of Americans for Muslims turns out both protests are covertly organized
by Russians connected to the Internet research agency.
According to the indictment,
the Americans did not know or they were communicating with Russians.
And it was this phrase,
I would have all of the ludicrous revelations of the indictment that really got
us thinking. Who were these unknowing Americans?
How did they end up at the fake protests and how do they think about it now?
So, producer, any Macewan and I, uh,
we started calling around and we found three people at the center of one of the
more famous fake protests, uh, mentioned in the indictment,
the so-called Florida flashmob.
We'll hear all about that after the break. This is Radiolab.
Will continue in a moment.
Hi there. This is Keirsten recording from Orlando, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abu Rod.
So after those indictments came down against the three Russian companies and 13
Russian nationals, uh, who were accused of, you know,
creating fake protest across the country. Our producers,
Simon Adler and Annie Mcewen got interested to try and locate some people who
had gone to these protests and maybe unwittingly took part in what was a covert
Russian operation and they managed to find three people.
All right. You can hear me? Yes, I can hear you fine. First up,
a woman named Ann Marie, Margaret Thomas, who lives in Florida.
I live in Jupiter, Florida currently and is in her 50s.
She works as a real estate agent and also,
oh, Shannon. Hi. Long to see you.
[inaudible]
the singer. Wow. Beautiful. She's also a huge Trump fan,
very active on Twitter. And in early August,
2016 she was contacted first on Twitter, then over the phone by two guys,
Joshua and Matt, UCLA students. They said they were, they were, um,
working with Hollywood producers,
Matt and Josh. And these are two people from Hollywood.
He's a film school, right? I don't know.
They didn't give me that much information,
but on the phone and thought Joshua's voice sounded familiar.
I better not, I shouldn't say who I think it is.
Who did you think it was? Come on just, yeah, I'm really curious.
Who Do I think it is? John Christopher. Who's that? Who's John? Christopher.
Yeah, he's really, his stage name is Johnny
[inaudible]. Huh?
Johnny.
Wait, this is Yani. The like orchestra new age piano. God Guy.
Yeah. Yeah.
But I think she's just guessing like there is no actual evidence linking Yani to
any of this. What was the organization they were working with? Uh, they, they,
this was the march for Trump group and they were a grassroots organization
started in the United States, Texas and California.
What did they ask you or what did they say when they contacted you?
Well, they were,
they said they were wanting to do rallies at a Hollywood people wanted to hire,
they actually want to hire three actors, one to play trunk,
one to play Bill Clinton and one
by Hillary. Interesting.
They basically told her that they want her to do this like performance art,
theater protest type thing.
Now at the same time she was talking to these guys on the other side of Palm
Beach County,
Mary Lauren. I'm retired. I'm active on Twitter to a point.
Another Trump fan guy by the name of Harry Miller,
who had a pretty big following,
the 70,000 someone in there, but
he also got contacted on Twitter and over the phone
there was a conversation about and desire to put on a, uh,
something like a flash mob or something and supporting Donald Trump.
Sorry, who was it that contacted you?
Uh, I believe his name is Matt.
What, what did Matt say in his original sort of communication?
This is extremely paraphrase because I don't have a distinct memory of all of
it.
And initially I was very suspect of him and the reason I was suspect is because
he had a, uh, a strong action.
And at the time there was a lot of commotion about Muslims and I thought he was
some who Islam of some kind. I was trying to set something up. And
what did his voice sound like?
It wasn't like deal, you know, or an American, you know, with articulate.
It was, it was broken.
Well, and so he, he said he wanted a flash mob. And what did he,
what did he say he wanted you to do?
He was asking me about making a trailer with a jail type of thing on it.
Essentially the guy with the accent told him,
I want you to stage an event where you have a cage and you're going to need to
build this cage,
but you're going to have this cage and at the event there will be a Hillary
Clinton impersonator and a Bill Clinton impersonator and I want you to put them
in the cage like you're putting them in jail and you should do this outside so
that lots of people can see you and they can chant, lock her up,
lock her up and you should take lots of photos and lots of videos and you should
send them to us.
And I did eventually say yes because he had an elaborate wedge butt site and he
told me it was part of a big group of people.
What did you remember the name of the website
being patriotic. It's dismantled according to the FBI. No.
In fact I tried to pull it off. I can't get it either.
What was odd is they insisted on paying me.
How did they end up paying for it?
They sent me to a check cashing place.
And how much money was it?
I found an estimate and I had written an estimate around $505 for it.
But it did come from out of the country. I do do recall that.
Can you describe what this, uh, once the construction was complete?
What your truck looked like?
Yeah, I, I, I have an s three 50 Ford pickup truck.
Big Truck. Yeah.
And I built a chain link fence,
three sides and then one side with a gate. Yeah. No, no, no. Four corners.
I had American flags of course.
Okay.
And there was a lot of talk about who was going to go in the cage and he and,
and he says, oh well we'll hire some actors. No one would play Trump.
No one would pay him.
And says the two quote UCLA guys suggested that she play Hilary.
And she agreed
and I made the costume.
I made the talking from a nursing outfit and on the back of that inmate.
So I went to the Hollywood master and I bought a full head mask of Hillary.
And so what were like, you're told to,
what were you told like show up at this place at this time? At this date,
and you just did it.
I don't know if you know in Palm Beach,
but it was sitting plays for in front of cheesecake factories where this
happened.
Harry was told to show up August 20th 1:00 PM. It's at the cheesecake factory.
That's where this was going to go down.
Boy, that was another thing. I kept asking him, are you going to be there?
Who's going to wear out? Who's going to run this? But where do I go? Oh No,
you just go to some place.
So he shows up in front of the cheesecake factory with his truck,
with a big cage. He'd built on the back and sure enough, there were people there
[inaudible]
including an [inaudible]. That was Hillary Clinton. We were given a script.
What was, what were your lines, do you remember?
Okay, have you been, see, let me see. Well we were,
I was supposed to talk about, um, my computer,
tablet and my email
and then I was persist. Um, tell some jokes.
She was there with her very good friend Greg,
who she convinced to be the Bill Clinton impersonator
yeah. At short and needed new money at the time. So
what did you do, Greg, to get, to prepare to play the part of, uh,
of Bill Clinton?
I had the shave shave.
Do you normally have like a mustache or something?
I shave once back in the 70s,
and I shaved again with when Jerry Garcia died and then I shaved when I had
played Bill Clinton.
Wait, you should, you've shaved like three times in your life. That's bad.
How did it feel to be in this cage along with Anne and be like this sort of
strange actor in this moving play?
Uh,
well first off it was hot and I was getting dark pollution and it was August and
it's Florida,
it's like 94 degrees and all I could think of was on one hand a beer.
Okay. That makes sense. I'm just wanting to be over.
So you didn't have very much fun. Yeah,
no, it wasn't a whole lot of fun. Yeah, it would just work.
Right. It was Annie having fun.
Well, yeah, I guess she was.
Bill was supposed to find a lady is that wouldn't be in it like standing around
like a news lady and trying to
flirt with her. Hey Bill, don't look now,
but I just seen Monica in jail. She was in the same apartment
and they sat in the carried for a while.
What you see in the Facebook live video is a few dozen people in the parking lot
outside the cheesecake factory and they're just standing around the cage with
Annie and side of it who is pretending to be sad about being locked up.
She was put a good actress, you know,
she's just exasperated and all that.
We spent a day doing that, took a lot of pictures,
had a good time.
Pictures of course, ended up on social media and according to Harry,
that thing on the Twitter and got over 500,000 hits in 24 hours.
You know,
you're aware that much of the much of the mainstream media at the moment is
reporting that, that this was a Russian,
like how does it make you feel that there's now this possibility that you were,
oh yeah, the FBI cam came here and talked to me about it.
Okay. When did, when did you speak with the FBI? Oh, they came to my house?
Yeah. How long ago? Last week. What did they ask you? Well,
they discussed with me pretty much what you were discussing with me,
but not in as much depth as you did.
Maybe the young guy was kind of an unexperienced.
He was tutored and Christian Bale too.
[inaudible] guy.
We reach out to the FBI. They responded with no comment.
Are you concerned that you may be part like that?
You may have been used as a puppet by people in St Petersburg?
No, I wasn't using the puppet.
Yeah, but would you have done it,
had they not reached out to you in the first place?
Well, I wanted to help Trump,
but this is a situation where our own federal government is telling you that a,
that this is essentially becoming an interstate conflict where Russia
intentionally, uh, manipulated people. Do you find that troubling?
Well, we're not all that stupid.
Harry Miller and me and his wife and veterans. No,
we're not that stupid. You know,
this whole thing has been investigated and I'm like known as the unwitting real
American.
So she's referring to a word that attorney general Rod Rosenstein used in the
press conference screen. Now these indictments, he said that these Russians,
they established social media pages and groups to communicate with unwitting
Americans
and wedding.
I W I'm the one whose idea was to put the date of Bengazi you on the prison
uniform. I'm waiting and I'm not a Russian. I'm an American.
And I decided that I didn't want to vote for Hillary.
Yeah. And I guess I'm not saying you're stupid at all. Like, well,
I think what's interesting here is I don't think you or Greg north or Harry
Miller,
I think that you all had really good intentions that you believed in this man
and you wanted to go ahead and support him.
And I think what gets complicated here now is we find out that even though you
supported this man, and maybe in the end of the day, you, you,
you helped him win,
that there was some nefarious work going on behind the scenes that led you to do
this. And I, I would have complicated feelings about that.
And I'm just trying to figure out if you do or don't.
No, because I did not believe that it'd be the case for the people that I dealt
with. I did not think it was a Russian movement.
I've got an article up here in front of me and in the indictment, uh,
they refer to Matt Schemer who is, I think the,
the Hollywood man that you talk to. They refer to him as, uh, an [inaudible].
He's from Texas and he went to UCLA. He was involved to a certain point.
And then he said he was going home.
Yeah. I'm,
I'm looking at a document right here saying that Matt skipper is an Adventist
person.
I, well, maybe that's an invented name, but I,
he was a young guy as e a family. Like what he said, he was like,
maybe he did give me a bogus name,
but you don't believe he was working for Russia?
Well, I don't know because they see lied about his name. Who knows? Yes.
What he told me, he said his name was Matt and he was using it. And the,
the email that I had was this Josh, um,
Josh Milton.
Um, I, I'll let you know that, um, Josh Milton,
they're saying is also a made up person.
No, but I'm might be wrong, but I'm not always,
I'm not usually wrong.
I think it's hilarious. I really do.
Because that obviously what happened from what I gather from this
is I was the one dealing with the Russian Trump.
How about that one?
What do you, what do you think about that? How does it make you feel?
Here's your tickets, Shelly, because you know, I, you know, I,
I don't think I'm stupid,
but I don't see I real motive here on how this could change any votes.
And they're claiming it disrupted the, uh, the election.
Uh, where does this interfere with our elections? I don't know.
I don't know how that could be. I really met again, had they nice contacts me.
I never in my whole life been up there. I'm going to page on that.
Hold on, Walker up here.
He says he understands that look invisible men on the other end of the phone
seem to want,
was he create a visual stunt one that they could then take on the road.
They wanted me to go to a New York.
Oh, they did. They wanted you to bring the cage to New York.
Yeah, I told him I wanted to watch some adverse that
and the whole thing to him was it,
it just didn't matter if it were Russians or not, but to, and from Greg,
the guy who played Bill Clinton,
he thinks about the whole thing very differently.
Um, well, um,
and I known that I was working for the Russians.
I would have asked for a lot more money.
Okay.
But I have never felt good about the thing because I might've had a little bit
of influence on sound from being elected.
And I think that was a mistake for America.
And he doesn't feel that way, but I do.
So is is the feeling almost assertive guilt?
Um, I'm not, I don't feel open.
I was being paid to do a job and I did the job and I did the job as to the best
of my ability. And people told me that I did the job well.
Okay. Well, so how does it feel to know that you were third of use?
I find a little irritating. Nobody likes to be used [inaudible]
irritating to me feels like a bit of a mild word for how I might feel.
Well,
okay.
I don't know. I'm thinking that this might be played on the radio,
so I can't really use the words that I would like to use. Uh,
man, I'm pissed as shit.
Well,
and it sounds like you and Anne have very different interpretations of whether
Russia was involved or not. Uh, does that get between your relationship?
Well, let's see.
[inaudible]
do I love nanny? Yes, I do
it very much.
Um, do we see eye to eye on everything? No, we don't. Um,
we all do crazy things for love. Even dress up like Bill Clinton,
shave our beards and go in a prison cage.
Oh, I've done crazier things than that, but I feel duped
as American, not by the Russians,
but by my fellow Americans.
The Russians can't come here and vote. We voted the way we wanted to vote.
I don't know if I'm making any sense from that.
Yeah, it sounds a little bit like you're saying that, uh,
what's frustrating is the fact that, uh,
it wasn't actually Russia that started the fire.
They were just blowing on it and maybe making it a little worse.
But the truly disheartening thing is the fact that the fire was ignited here
without Russia.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. That's exactly what I'm trying to say. I mean,
I can't, I can't, I like that.
I can't talk about this anymore. Call back sometime.
[inaudible]
excellent. I got something to say about everything. I'm old, man.
Okay, well we'll make use of it.
All right, Greg. Okay. Thank you very much. Thank you, man. Bye. Bye. Bye now.
This piece was produced by Simon Adler and Andy Mcewen.
We had reporting assistance from Becca Bressler and Charles mains.
Very special thanks to Casey,
Michelle and Laura Isensee and uh,
of course Tijani I'm Jad Abumrad. Thank you guys for listening.